generally speaking would you be more
attracted to a man that's over six foot
or around that region there in
comparison to someone let's say my
height five foot seven
with with a good personality naturally
with your instincts what do you feel
you're selling yourself well I love it
Hey listen
I will keep it bro
I feel like we should be diplomatic if
we were like broken that much well
personally I've
height like it doesn't bother me whether
they're the same height as me taller
shorter whatever like I am much more of
an emotional person than I am sort of
that side of things that's not what I
initially go for it's like that
connection with the person I don't care
whether they're taller than me or not or
whether they've got you know a dart
board or a six-pack like that aesthetic
side of it isn't important obviously
you've got to have an attraction
somebody to want to be with them but I
don't think I would necessarily go for
somebody who's got those Norms if they
do they do but that's not what I
intentionally look for
three inches shorter than you yes yeah
who said no me okay at least you're
honest I think no I haven't I'm being
better and I would date somebody who's
the same height as me but personally I
would just feel like um you see if I
wear heels I understand like there is
that element but I would overall like to
be with a man that's at least the same
height as me or taller because it just
makes me feel like I don't know it I
think it's more masculine I'm just
attracted to that
um
personally
um and I had like the best connection
with someone and you honestly were like
this person is my soul mate like I I
have I can get on with them better than
anyone else and I generally want to you
know spend the rest of my life with them
whatever but then you go oh actually
there's a few he's a few inches shorter
than me I'm just being realistic because
you see I'm I'm not necessarily like a
man like a visual creature but you know
the first thing you look at is actually
looks so even if let's say you're not my
usual type or there is something about
you that's you know like oh you're not
my perfect type I feel like there needs
to be that sort of Attraction and if
there's no attraction between me and
that person I would just see them more
as a friend per se and that's just me
personally no I do agree with you in
that sense like in terms of your
original question would I date a guy
that's your high or not the same height
as me yes I would if someone was three
inches shorter than me no I wouldn't
mainly because I like to wear heels
that's just me personally so I would
just feel like I'm just towering over
that person but um yeah to Echo and what
you said it you when you first meet
someone it is that initial attraction
and I don't think if I'm being
completely honest I would be initially
attracted to someone that is three
inches shorter than me especially
because I'm actually quite short in any
way but that's just my personal opinion
but I wouldn't I would date someone I
don't have to be six foot that's not in
my criteria but it's taller than you at
least that would be ideal but even if
you updated someone that's been exactly
the same height as me if you're the same
height I think I think his point is that
women generally like taller men yeah in
general can I can I suggest that maybe
do women like that because it kind of
emphasizes their femininity like when
you're larger than a man you kind of
naturally feel like oh maybe I'm not as
feminine as I should be yeah no it just
makes you feel a little bit more petite
and um kind of like what you were saying
it does make the man feel a little bit
more masculine masculine when he's a bit
bigger than you and you just yeah it
just feels feels nicer appreciate it
but is that they're not the same kind of
thing if I was to say look lizzo is not
my type but yeah because of her her size
and majority of men would think like
that is that not we're not going towards
the same kind of but then I'm not I'm
what I'm not arguing about that I'm
saying I wouldn't necessarily look at
lizard and be like oh just because she's
um 300 pounds she's a father she's a
five I wouldn't say that yeah
it depends just are you just basing that
off weight like what are you basing
enough if you actually look at lizzo I
actually think it's a very beautiful
woman when you look at it you're just
basically no partially yeah I would base
it off of if you put lizzo in front of
100 people what they would rate her one
to ten most people would rate her below
average and is that because you're
looking at that based on her size yeah I
mean you're less attractive if you're
fat but then I wouldn't I see I don't
agree with that yeah I I don't agree
with you I think yeah but that's
personal opinion and a lot of people
will sort of make a judgment on an
initial viewing of somebody so the first
time you see someone or the first time
you speak to someone you jump to a
conclusion and you judge them whether
you mean to or not and you're a
judgmental person or not but then it's
whether you
you know you give them give them a
chance to I'm not saying they don't have
any qualities I'm just saying that like
First Impressions like you're rating
people by look yeah like everyone
everyone
like sort of decides whether they think
they're gonna be I don't know attracted
to somebody friends with somebody on
their first impression some people will
take it further and actually want to get
to know that person other people will
stop at that point and then go no
further and not want to get to know that
I've got to be honest with ladies I'm
sorry you have the power in terms of the
majority of the pool so you are choosing
you've always got the choice I'm sorry
you're not giving a guy you don't find
attractive a chance to even get there so
there's no personality test there's no
none of this get to know him because
you've already
um you're given access to who you want
to especially if you like all the ladies
in this room you have a lot more Choice
than a lot of others so if a guy's 300
pounds overweight and you're not into
that that this unlikely is even going to
get that chance so that's why I kind of
debunked that theory of I wouldn't date
this or that because you always got
those kind of choices and if it was true
if women weren't picky about looks one
and three men want to be virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year one out
of three like women are very picky when
it comes to look in some some studies
say that women are more picky about
looks than men 100 I think it's
preference I think it's just your
preference and what your type is some
some girls women like bigger men or men
that are not athletic and some men do
like bigger set women it is your
preference some men like short women
some men like Brunette blonde hair just
is your preference would you say we can
get honest data about what we prefer
based on dating apps I don't use dating
apps I mean in general I couldn't tell
you that like did you say that like it
says something about by and large
because that's the number one way people
are meeting nowadays would you say by
and large we can get some information
about what men and women look for 100
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so when women
only swipe right between five to fifteen
percent of the time where men swipe
right fifty percent
so so women are much more selective and
picky than men
it's hard for you guys to articulate it
because you don't you wouldn't ever go
there and describe it you just wouldn't
because is that also because men and
women are using dating apps to look for
different things personally I have never
been on a dating app I've been in two
long-term relationships since I've sort
of you know been old enough to be in
serious relationships whatever I've
never dated around I've never
um been on a dating app at all I've seen
it on my friend's phones but that's it
so I don't know whether men and women
are using it for different things are
men just using it to get laid and all
women using it because it's a normal
thing to find people now are they using
that to you know look for a long-term
relationship why they're being more
picky all I can look at is the results
and it's the number one way people are
meeting for long-term relationships too
I just wanted to I'm sure I'm sure
short-term I'm sure they I'm sure I mean
when when dating apps first came about
that was kind of the main thing that I
was under the impression useful like
tender yeah yeah I think you make a good
point though I like that I would agree
with that that be the the intention of
why they're on the app changes things
because if you're looking to date
someone for something important or like
long term that I'm not swiping on 70
people like I'm more very concerted
decisions but if I'm just looking for
like oh what's happening tonight swipe
on everybody and see who responds right
but then to that what I will say as well
that I would say women are more likely
to go on data now so